the mind
and
like my pregnant wife
a liter of gasoline
[Music]
we sang
with so much oil so much wealth that there is
in venezuela we do not deserve a country
like we have today
deteriorated because of those who are in the regime
in power venezuela is  right
now living what was their main
nightmare they want to attend the end of their
oil era
[Music]
venezuela is the world orchestra is
people with trias
[Music]
even social with
capacitor pumps current from the ground water
finer on youtube
but suárez  to bring them closer to the economy
knows where he sang and zbik wide expansion
for longer the strong sell crops
teleseries subscription manual in
our book black market
andrés caracas this expert has existed
christians and private in his elections
[Music]
when
black about it leave region they usually live
subsists more tense pp actuators look
what work does not produce from the hill they
prefer to have the bus stopped par  to
pour gasoline and resell resell the
gasoline say with the money he earned I
don't understand the bus talks to him
[Music]
and he spends more than 32 65 liters a
day but hey, he doesn't have to make
a big ball to pour them today even
we do
the same  pump guards
ask us for my team maps that come in
the tank properly because
40 liters that help the government that is
working up and down
await the great Caracas to
produce what it has to produce something
to maintain
the  people keep a lot of the ticket for
the model that a passenger has thinks
that these 600 rubber
when he recovered those 50 brief tickets
a hose or a simple way a
little step way how to say everything of water
is 20 dollars
the maximum daily car that can give 45
dollars  It would be 20 for me, 20 for the
owner of the car and 5 for the collector,
to put it that way, when it was recovered
, the tire belts cost 600 dollars,
but what even exists  the verb
consisted previously they will be for
venezuela normally but victories
outside of swing to urge and grace jones
of the course this one suffers a british mind
parts
[Music]
david wilson i
have a business but somehow
satisfy the need
at
work level i have enough people
left the  mechanical service to the
vehicles that are people and I worked there for
ages that cannot be
served for not even eight hours and two
days a week I am the one who has
sacrificed time
2 finishes eating
I was not going to place it at  price
where we must win first
the issue of living
and the tasty legion is already cumbersome and then what you
have to do to be able to withdraw it
so as to place it in detroit
sad that we have a country
with so much wealth
and now nothing not even the same
fuel that we live produced  en
masse and now we have to be very
important
[Music]
before totals between venezuela state
bongo champions
[Music]
l  The current administration, the last 20 or
25 years of government, took it upon themselves to
destroy the few that had been planted with
oil, because the oil always remained,
the non-oil economy and,
well, through the process of
appropriation from controls of upon
controls of the economy, etc.
they left us that they calculated that they
eliminated the economy those who tolerated
not only that they were also
the economy that I had pedevesa came to
have more than 20 references in the world 6
in venezuela but we had no other
countries for example in the united states
we were  site owners
sigo came to have 78 large refineries
in the united states came to have
oil pipelines that crossed that country from
south to north came to have 15,750
service stations flagged under
the seed go brand and we are going to have 36
terminals in fact we arrived  to
control 10 percent of the
most important domestic gasoline market in the world keren
from the usa
we were able to  take our
oil from our underground to the
gas tank to the
American motorists spending all the time
to be the Venezuelans Venezuelan wells
Venezuelan products
tankers Venezuelan supertankers
Venezuelan refineries it was already we had
created a gigantic thing but at that
moment there was a costly
historic accident in  venezuela won chávez the
elector commander hugo chávez
cold before god and before the pure country
you faithfully fulfill the duties
inherent to the position of
constitutional president of venezuela hugo chávez lives it in
force to be a
venezuela in ninety nine in openoffice
is transferred from sporting lasts in
active being true social is a
product or version of the tenor of the
prosperous contain the anr
then the regional on the ground jesús
chávez rebel constitution when they
speak to you national film libraries collectives
between companies have destroyed national
transitory of inflation counts enough
you  sis against the perverse entrance
suited him well lend from nation strike
fighters fire and dyed in exterior
workers in turin
[Music]
announced the dismissal dismissal of the
following people
eddy ramírez managing director until
today of palmavén outside
Mr. Juan Fernández is fired from
petroleums of venezuela i have no
problem scraping them all if they
had to scrape them all i have
no problem i
fired 20,000 workers from pedrés
each of them on average had 15
years working for the industry
so they threw it into the wastebasket  garbage
300,000 years of experience and
knowledge that is easy to say but the
impact was brutal instead of
producing 56 million barrels
per day what should we be
producing in venezuela the latest
monthly opec report locates our
production based on secondary sources
at 339 thousand barrels per
day today
after having a
gigantic importance  in the world of oil
today we are a marginal producer and an
insignificant exporter of oil, I
think that soon there will be
a problem, a problem of protecting this
something, because see if we have
diesel, such as bars after street food, well
he will not see why diesel is
mostly because it is not heavy transport
to move food or all that
so people are going to start doing things
in the streets
in son-in-law of the journey the
social taxpayer sometimes in excess venezuela in
victoria nicolás mature
snow  world intervene by knocking down juan the
fifth camper of housing control
[Music]
mengual in the permanent trade of the
domus spei volkmar day is to train
services protect mind sporting this
project but had venezuela
contributed our number is for the
typical to relate blue
[Music]